[Music]
all right so this next story
is very tragic and sad and i would
appreciate you guys to have a lot of
[ __ ] respect all right
a 29 year old upstate new york man who
covered himself in hand sanitizer burst
into flames after police use a taser on
him oh [ __ ] dude
oh my god flames that's crazy why did he
cover himself in enhancement because
kobe love it bro can you shower [ __ ]
coffee is this jake gyllenhaal i know he
doesn't shower every day oh yeah what's
up with that dude why are all these
celebrities talking about not showering
yes
watch out guys wait is it that whole
movement where we don't use shampoo and
all these things and we just don't
shower and we let our natural body
[ __ ] do it
do the thing is that a movement or is
that just regular degeneracy lack of
movement yeah i think that shouldn't
juna is talking about it on dax
shepard's uh podcast and it was mila
kunis ashton kutcher basically saying
like they don't shower every day and
they don't like shower their kids every
day they're busy parents and she grew up
in the ukraine where there weren't a lot
of showers so it was kind of normal for
her ashton had adopted it after they
were together for a while and then uh a
bunch of people were like ew you guys
are [ __ ] dirty
uh jake gyllenhaal came out and said
that he doesn't die
i heard that american hygiene's
different like what like we shower like
morning and night and then like we do
all the [ __ ] shampooing and all that
stuff like like that's our normal but
then like are like in europe like they
don't like [ __ ] wash their hair every
day and all that [ __ ] like the third
world country places that don't have
running water well they don't got
running water right but like here i can
understand i was always told you can't
walk because i don't think ukraine's a
third world country man yeah i do i do
know that
ladies usually say that you don't wash
your hair every day right because then
that'll [ __ ] up your hair natural oils
which actually technically your actual
body has similar
elements to it too so not showering
every day is supposed to be actually
good for your skin versus drying it out
all the time with like quote unquote
cleaning that's
because like now that i have long hair
and then like it's dry as [ __ ] right now
man my hair [ __ ] i got dandruff like
frosted flakes and cereals like me too
bro being [ __ ] created in my head
dude me too i got the whole cereal
factory right here you want to make it
rain for a sec
wash your hair every other day
i need my oils to come back huh you got
to train your during the summer when i'm
in hawaii when i'm in like these moist
ass places no problem
i'm not made for this weather you don't
have eczema or anything like eggs no i'm
eczema's i think food and and hormonal
but like not really weather
but then because this is smooth right
now man i'm not [ __ ] i'm healthy as
[ __ ]
some elbows
dandruff and dry skin
boy i bet the lotion can't
reach i gotta do this what happens if
you're active like if you like sweat on
a regular basis
you should be showering pretty
consistently right that's why i shower
right now yeah you should yeah end of
story right yeah yeah it depends you
shower most of the time how about that i
guess everybody's got a fair middle
ground yeah
how about you shower
but you don't use soap because i know
someone that was experimenting with
water
how about the dude that got [ __ ] lit
on fire with [ __ ] anti-bacterial all
over him getting tased he was pretty
wild actually like why was he getting
tased so he he got tased by police um
this is this is the man by the way oh
this is him before he got him before
he's on fire i thought he was
breastfeeding a child he don't look
burnt
that guy he knows he's a hoax and we're
not sure he's covered in lotion at this
point or not
he looks like he's breastfeeding a child
with his pants around his ankles
what a scene show the picture show the
picture
the world needs to see this guy's a
pervert well you saw him feeding a child
he looks like he's breastfeeding a child
with his pants around his ankles dude
[Laughter]
with a pants around his ankle what an
innocent photo of a regular guy yeah
yeah
so
holy [ __ ] you're caught on fire
this is the after photo
[Laughter]
god damn yeah he's in there he's in
there somewhere he can't really see
how
much god dammit steve
hand sanitizer did this full use on his
body the police have buckets
buckets and buckets so he tried to layer
himself like a stripper is that the term
is it shut the [ __ ] up
the police said buckets and buckets
if you rub that [ __ ] on your balls
doesn't that burn huh yeah i'm sure
because you know how it's got that
menthol freshness like when you touch it
in your you're just like that's so fresh
it depends on how many open sores you
have
right after you [ __ ] fix his balls
dude stage leprosy you currently have
wouldn't it dry the [ __ ] out of your
skin yeah for sure it's alcohol right
now i always want to lotion that [ __ ]
that's some covent proof balls baby
first of all how did this like cute
looking man get tased in the first place
you mean the breastfeeder yeah the
breastfeeder would like me that's right
dude pants down breastfeeding he entered
the village of catskill police
department last week he walks into the
police department right in new york and
he gets into a confrontation with the
officers right
and then police told the paper that
jones who was known to them from
previous encounters appeared intoxicated
and at that point they felt they needed
to use the taser to subdue him
and yeah he just burst into flames
instantaneously burst into flames yeah
personal plane and then he started
running around and that hand sanitizer
acted like a wick huh
yeah but then he was so slippery from
all the sand sometimes nobody could
catch him dude
[Laughter]
just gak
[Laughter]
turn into a flight is he okay
no he's dead oh [ __ ] for real yeah he
died he died instantaneously the police
said he felt no pain instant people the
police said he felt
run around and then instantaneously died
they they said that they're burying his
nike air maxes
as they said that's the only thing
that's left
man they always take pictures they give
people pictures like that where it's all
cute and [ __ ] so you feel bad for the
victim let me see the articles dude can
i see the article yeah you can't yeah
i want to see the moment when he was in
the police station drunk getting tasered
that's what i want to see
they say intoxicated because they smell
hand sanitizer alcohol it's not even
real alcohol yeah
what if he just came in with a complaint
and they're like shut up and then they
[ __ ] shot his ass
they just didn't want to do paperwork
well like it's just complaining about
how they're like shooting his dog or
some [ __ ] you know
that's it
he's like a nice old dude
the breastfeeder he's breastfeeding his
dog
shut it off
the cops like shut up yes shot your dog
and then [ __ ] shoot this guy's nypd
dude nypd no there is good news he's he
is alive um but he said he was dead i
misread it
i think he's on the inside like he's
dead on the end yeah yeah yeah he has no
nervousness anymore no it says that um
yeah
he's he's alive but his condition is not
great and uh the incident's under
investigation by the district attorney
damn so this is the birth of two-face no
it's actually just one face because you
burnt all around it's probably got one
like fourth degree burned layer and then
looking melted face
oh my god pronounced dead on the inside
because like even with hand sanitizer
right it's like you put that [ __ ] on
like it's gonna fall off and dry
you would have to have such an insane
amount like all over your mustache
buckets
bro let's experiment do we gotta hash on
the top i know we gotta get lighter
that's right i could have a taser
i could use a lighter yeah we have some
hand sanitizers yeah this this is one of
those bad ideas that i want to see all
the way through we have to do this hey
welcome to an episode of jk science with
steve green and joe do we have hand
sanitizer anywhere we do got a taser
somewhere ryan where's the taser taser
no hand sanitizer that sounds about
right for this office
regular alcohol can we just tase the
bottle do something happen let's cut
real quick and do this experiment all
right let's look for it we probably have
hand sanitizer from 2013. let's yeah
squirt some on the table and see what
happens all
better or worse you think there's so
many issues with this moment
yeah
there was a guy you should train with
and um
after we would train he would have a
whole bottle of hand sanitizer this is
way before kovit and he would pump it
and put it on like sunscreen
yeah just after we would train so i
should probably hit him up and tell him
like hey you shouldn't be doing anything
be careful
hand sanitizer hey dude i have some in
my car but i wasn't thinking about using
it we got a gas tank for real yeah let's
do it all right i gotta i don't know
where the let's cut i know we have a
taser because we did it as a jk party
challenge i love it let's do it
all right we're doing this oh yeah it's
all right i remember that
we found it we got hand sanitizer all
right i would say this is probably
equivalent to buckets on his skin okay
we couldn't find my taser though uh
but i did find a gun but i you know in
this situation it wasn't a gun
so uh what we did find was a lighter
here and we should move back huh yeah i
got got
i got a shot glass yes
but i got it in the glass so if it goes
on fire would do you know and then um
i'll use this to take it out
all right closer to anthony though ready
welcome to jk science folks
son of a [ __ ] is
it didn't catch on fire
it's on fire
it's on fire it's [ __ ] on fire it's
blue oh it actually is burning holy [ __ ]
can you see that [ __ ] you son of a
[ __ ] at home wow
can you see it so yeah we can confirm jk
can now confirm that that guy was set on
fire by a taser
dude that shit's falling [ __ ] that's
just flaming you can barely see it
though
damn you use the [ __ ] ton of my hand
sanitizer oh is that yours it's a waste
of hand sanitizer
it's on fire it's not stopping it's not
stopping just like what happened i
wanted a big fire
it's probably bigger than we think it
looks pretty big i can see the vapor are
we all on crack right now no there's a
spider
we're all doing come here cat come here
how could your hands how come you can't
how come it can't be on camera brian
says that it burns invisibly ryan caught
it huh he'd be called him
why well
here's the here's the way to test it
on top of it like this that's good all
right ready
yo it's burning there's blue
professor there's only one way to prove
it
closer to the camera
close to the camera just in case you're
not sure
oh
is it off
oh how about this we set that on fire
then we put it in there no more did you
turn it off it's off the worst science
class i've ever been on put it back on
is all the alcohol gone now is it just
gel get the paper on just the paper on
fire with the lighter
no let's burn other stuff is it on fire
it's no longer it's on fire bro
yeah that [ __ ] works
dude look at this [ __ ]
limp
i know dude i didn't think that was
gonna light up and i'm i'm very happy
that it is so thanks for watching jk
special episode jk science sponsored by
t-mobile
this is hot now
don't drink out of this guys
i'ma just leave it on
you